[Music]
welcome back to the 18 t Pebble Beach
pro-am here with the dinettes and
joining us is one of the stars for NCIS
Los Angeles he's Chris O'Donnell good to
see you Chris Oh life's good you know
this kind of weather you're from Chicago
so this isn't bad for you right you know
this is your typical Monterey California
weather here this is we've been so lucky
the last couple years we matter in short
sleeve shirt so this is a lot more
typical and it's good what's the worst
weather you ever played golf in oh god I
played one time in Turnberry in Scotland
and I'm ever getting halfway out and
just you literally couldn't even advance
a ball and we all tried we had to walk
back in and I think it's now our key to
get back to the clubhouse it was the
weather was so bad but it's been bad out
here I've had to count the tournament
canceled twice on me
which what's it about golf that
fascinates you um well I mean it's just
so hard so you're constantly trying to
get better but it's what I grew up with
we grew up on a little course called
West Shore up in Douglas Michigan as a
little par 66 course and it's just my
childhood and my older brother was a
really good player it's still a really
good player and you know as I get older
and got out of school and started
working on films you'd find yourself all
over the world and random places but if
you got on a golf course it was a sense
of I feel like I'm home again and this
feels very comfortable to me when you're
an actor you get takes when you're a
golfer you don't get takes well not a
tournament you get retakes unfortunately
but that's the thing and it's like my
little boys play a lot of tournaments
off and it's such a good thing because
tournament golf is so different and you
have so many people that play golf at
home and think well geez I shot par I
could play with these guys they have no
idea you know this isn't even a major
but for us you know if suddenly your
your your partner makes a bogey and
you're on the 18th hole at Pebble and
you're getting a shot and all of a
sudden your putt means something it's a
four foot five you know your hearts
racing you know people are watching it
and it's it's not easy and it's
televised too and it's televised and
they announce your name and the first
tee I mean it you get some jitters going
we actually did some homework on you we
don't do homework on all of our guests
but we did homework beyond the actual
just Wikipedia page and did some
homework yeah life is boiled down to
about three stories that are on
Wikipedia okay and that's about it
give me it's like nothing else has ever
happened give me the three stories
though just did it I did a commercial
with Michael Jordan for McDonald's
Barbra Streisand called me at school or
cast me in a movie at one point said I
went to law school which I wanted them
to keep up they took that down and
what's the other story I can't remember
the other story okay but Jordan you were
in a McDonald yeah commercial wood that
was you you serve I was in the
McDonald's polyester outfit and I served
him his breakfast yeah what do you
remember about that it was a crazy day
cuz it rained 10 inches that day and so
we were Jordan was six hours late for
the shoot so we just I was hanging out
in a McDonald's you know for six hours
waiting for Michael to arrive and he
came and it was awesome and yeah have
you met him since then to tell you I did
I was when while the Batman films were
coming out Leno came to Chicago he was
doing a show in Chicago and uh it you
know suddenly people knew who I was
because I had been in a couple Batman
films so they thought it's funny I
brought him his food to this so now
here's another one
help us were you up for the movie Rudy
no I I knew the guys um there's a Cary
broke who I think was perusing it I knew
the guys but I was laughing Rudy was on
the other night and I was watching it
it's a good movie I know Shawn I know
Sean Astin but what's so funny is they
filmed when they're playing Jorge
attacked they're actually it was the day
Notre Dame was playing Boston College so
I was at the game and if you scan the
crowd everyone's in BC sweatshirts and
hats in holding up signs so it was you
never up guys you did research on this
Polly Dean I did research on this we
didn't say he was up for Rudy we said he
should've been you could have pulled
that off yeah definitely definitely no I
remember that came around but do you
always I don't know it has to drive you
crazy when somebody says what are the
movies you passed on right that's always
a sensitive subject well because it's
hard to say that a movie would have been
a success I mean you know I passed on
men in black you know and it wouldn't be
in the same movie Will Smith you know
Will Smith probably me some hours on
NetJets for you know they made him
pretty sore but the movie would not been
the same with myself in time Willie
Jones and you know I didn't even know
what they were making at the time there
wasn't
script you know I just done a Batman
film I couldn't do another cartoon movie
so to speak at the time at least that
was my thinking and it became this
enormous movie but you know to beat
yourself up over decisions like that or
is crazy he's Chris O'Donnell the star
of NCIS Los Angeles with LL Cool J why
does it work with LL Cool J um you know
where it's a good combo and it's
interesting I think it was Nina Tassler
was running CBS television at the time
who was her idea to put us together
you were very different people we had
very different upbringings
but at the core we we share a lot of the
same values
we've both have been around the block
many times and realized what a great
opportunity it was and so we were there
to work hard and make it you know go in
and say we're gonna work as hard as we
can to make this make this a success and
and it just turned out that our
chemistry was really good together you
know we sit there and I Drive him crazy
all day long you know he says I'm the
master of as he calls it plausible BS
because I just make stuff up and he
can't tell if I'm serious or if I'm
screwing with them can you rap now have
you ever tried to run out or not going
to try to rap now no I'm pretty sure I
know that most of the words you know
Sugar Hill Gang Rapper's Delight but I'm
gonna keep that to myself
when people see you what did they say
what's the one thing that I mean it was
always ALPA Chino you know what was it
like to work that Patino and then the
Batman thing was a big deal you know the
Robin comment and the whole thing but
this show we've been on for eight years
now and it's been a great success and
our fans are fantastic and the people
will stop me now and say hey I love your
show I just wanted to tell you oh my god
preacher he goes no no I really like
they want you to know they're genuine
and that's really nice because they are
but we have the most were eight years
we've had the best numbers we've had
this year I mean it's going strong and
and we're real fortunate give me a story
I don't know about sensible woman with
Pacino I got I just saw al he got the
Kennedy Center award this year and they
called me up they're like so we have a
crazy idea we want you to dance the
tango in honor of it
with Gabrielle on where I said well you
know I wasn't the one dancing on the
show but we ended up doing it was fun I
don't know my I I was so young and green
and I knew what an opportunity it was
but you know I was amazing Philip
Seymour Hoffman who unfortunately passed
away that was one of his first films and
I go back and I can now see the film and
I watched it right before I went back to
for the Kennedy Center Honors and and I
can finally appreciate the film because
for so many years you can't stop
watching and thinking oh god to use that
taker you know you're just you can't get
caught up in it
wait you're beating yourself up over it
we always do 20 now I don't know I know
but I'm saying I hadn't seen the movie I
mean my kids it and then I was talking
to my kid my kids and we were in New
York City for Thanksgiving I was
pointing out some things I said remember
that from the movie they go what are you
talking about they've never seen it
they've never seen like half the films
him in so we're gonna have to have a
little Film Festival at home and
introduce my children to some of the
films you said you were Green in that
movie yeah but I did a few films before
but I still didn't play to your
strengths just be absolutely and part of
the thing was when I when I did the
movie Marty breasts the director told he
knew I was nervous around al and he said
you know let's keep your distance this
is this is good and he's uncomfortable
it worked for the characters and
honestly you know I'm sure when it came
down to the final guys for that role
there were actors that were much more
talented than I was but I think part of
who I was in real life
combined with the way I interpreted the
the role was what when we depart hey I
want to thank you well thank your
brother I Johnny oh I like I wear the
clothing line I like it and then I find
out somebody says oh it's Johnny O's oh
you know his brother Chris I go why yeah
he's got it Chris O'Donnell was Johnny
O's brother so got a clothing line there
we had a dice it was funny to say that
we had Jim Nantz had a very funny thing
I did for John's 40th birthday I had a
surprise party for him and Nance did
this funny video where he he starts out
it's kind of blurry and says so Tommy
happy 50th you're great friends see you
soon
all right LAN said that's it I gotta go
sold on hold on we got one more he's
like come on last this is ridiculous
I've done enough disease no no it's for
John O Donnell egos who the hell is John
O Donnell I know Kristen don't know what
help John is he goes screw it let's just
roll let's just roll so all this is
airing the people in the audience like
oh my god this is so embarrassing he
goes John O Donnell happy 40th you're a
great friend I love your body wish I was
there and then all sudden he comes back
he's like Johnny oh because he actually
does know John it was really sweet
well maybe you could help my guys with
some Johnny O's to help them we'll get
you guys some gear I'll get you
outfitted could I play a dead body yeah
all right let's do it do you want to be
shot or you just want a dead body like
that hold opening dead body on the
ground or do you want to actually be
shot I don't know if I'm capable of
acting like I've been shot though Chris
I mean I you know what when those those
things go off you feel like you've been
shot
special effects come in oh really yeah I
don't miss very often on the show I
gotta tell you I went hunting over
Thanksgiving we went to New York I went
pheasant hunting and I was I couldn't
shoot anything this birds
ten feet in front of me and I've got
this bullet that sprays like that and I
still can't hit the damn thing so he's
Chris O'Donnell you can see him every
Sunday night on NCIS Los Angeles at 8:00
Eastern on CBS
Chris thank you for stopping by good to
be here good luck with giannios thank
you very much the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]